♪ ♪
>> Dana: BACK TO OUR TOP
STORY.
SENATORS ARE STILL REVIEWING THE
AFGHAN REPORT ON BRETT KAVANAUGH
IS THE PARTISAN BATTLE HEATS UP
OVER THE FINDINGS AND THE SENATE
GEARS UP FOR A CRITICAL
CONFIRMATION VOTE.
HOW ARE REPUBLICANS REACTING TO
THE FBI'S KAVANAUGH REPORT?
WE BRING IN SENATOR JOHN CORNYN
FROM THE GREAT STATE OF TEXAS
FOR THE VERY LATEST.
IT'S VERY GOOD TO HAVE YOU,
SENATOR.
CAN YOU HELP US UNDERSTAND ALL
OF THIS?
I WANT TO ASK YOU, DO YOU THINK
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE MANAGED IN
ALL OF THIS TO ENERGIZE THE
REPUBLICANS AND DISAPPOINT THEIR
OWN BASE?
>> I THINK WHEN WE CONFIRM BRETT
KAVANAUGH, WHICH I PREDICT WE
WILL, ON SATURDAY, I THINK THAT
WILL BE THE OUTCOME.
WE COULD HAVE HAD A MORE
DIGNIFIED WAY TO CONSIDER
DR. FORD'S ALLEGATIONS THROUGH
THE NORMAL PROCESS.
SINCE SENATOR FEINSTEIN SAT ON
THOSE ALLEGATIONS WERE ABOUT SIX
WEEKS AND DROP THEM ON US AFTER
THE HEARING, THE FIRST HEARING
ON JUDGE KAVANAUGH, WE GOT INTO
THIS I THINK CIRCUS WHERE THERE
WERE NO RULES.
THE END SEEM TO JUSTIFY THE
MEANS.
YEAH, THIS COULD HAVE BEEN
HANDLED MUCH BETTER AND I THINK
IN A WAY THAT WOULD'VE BEEN MORE
DIGNIFIED, MORE PROTECTIVE OF
DR. FORD AND THE JUDGE.
>> Dana: WE ARE GOING TO TAKE
IT AROUND THE TABLE, SIR.
>> Judge Jeanine: SENATOR,
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
I NOTICE THAT YOU YOUR TIME TO
THE PROSECUTOR.
IN THE END, WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR IS TO HAVE THE PUBLIC KNOW
WHAT'S IN THOSE FBI THREE OH TWO
REPORTS.
YOU KNOW THAT THAT WOULD
ESTABLISH A PRECEDENT.
DON'T YOU THINK IT WOULD BE A
DANGEROUS PRECEDENT.
I HAVE AN IDEA.
THAT IS IF THEY, IF YOU WANT TO
GIVE THEM THE FBI REPORT, HOW
ABOUT THEY GIVE YOU THE
THERAPIST NOTES?
>> THAT WOULD BE THE ORDINARY
PROCEDURE, AS YOU KNOW, JUDGE.
BUT THE REASON WHY WE DECIDED TO
ASK RACHEL MITCHELL TO ASK THE
QUESTIONS OF DR. FORD IS BECAUSE
WE KNOW WE WOULD'VE BEEN
CRITICIZED FOR HAVING AN AGING
-- AGING WHITE MAN ASKING A
VICTIM OF SEXUAL ASSAULT HARD
QUESTIONS.
WE REALLY NEEDED TO HAVE ANSWERS
TO THE QUESTIONS IN ORDER TO
TEST HER STORY.
AS YOU KNOW, THERE'S BEEN NO
CORROBORATION WHATSOEVER.
IN FACT, ALL OF THE PEOPLE SHE
HAS IDENTIFIED HAVE REFUTED HER
VERSION OF THE STORY.
BUT AGAIN, SOMETHING HAPPENED TO
DR. FORD.
BUT WE WEREN'T GIVEN THE BENEFIT
OF HER THERAPIST NOTES WHICH I
THINK WOULD HAVE SHED A LOT OF
LIGHT ON IT.
>> Jesse: HEY, SENATOR CORNYN.
HAS YOUR RELATIONSHIP WITH YOUR
SENATE DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES ON
THE OTHER SIDE FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGED AFTER HOW THEY BEHAVED
WITHIN THE LAST TWO MONTHS?
I HAVE NEVER SEEN CHUCK
GRASSLEY, WHO IS PRETTY
EVEN-TEMPERED, SO ANIMATED AND
SO ANGRY AND SOME OF THE
BEHAVIOR COMING OUT OF THE OTHER
SIDE THAT IT LOOKS TO ME LIKE
IT'S BEYOND REPAIR.
WHAT'S YOUR ASSESSMENT OF YOUR
RELATIONSHIP NOW?
>> MY FAVORITE CHUCK GRASSLEY
SAYING IS JUST BECAUSE I'M
YELLING AT YOU DOESN'T MEAN I'M
MAD AT YOU.
THIS IS STRAINED RELATIONSHIPS.
THE TRUST THAT'S ALWAYS
IMPORTANT, PARTICULARLY IN THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
WE UNDERSTAND WE ARE ADULTS AND
WEEDS -- WE KNOW WHAT'S AT STAKE
HERE.
WE HAVE DIFFERENT VIEWS.
WE'VE BEEN GETTING A LOT OF
THINGS DONE UNDER THIS
ADMINISTRATION WITH REPUBLICAN
MAJORITIES IN THE HOUSE AND
SENATE.
THIS PROCESS IS NOT ONE I WOULD
EVER WANT TO SEE REPEATED FOR
ANYBODY FOR ANY NOMINEE,
REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRAT NOR FOR
ANY WITNESS.
I THINK IT'S BEEN SHAMEFUL.
>> Dana: GREG GUTFELD.
CASE, SENATOR  .
I'VE NOTICED A LOT OF LAWS BEING
BROKEN.
AN INTERN WHO DOXXED A NUMBER OF
REPUBLICANS WHO WERE
PRO-KAVANAUGH.
THAT FELLOW, COSKO, WAS
ARRESTED.
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN TO HIM.
IS ANYTHING GOING TO BE DONE
WITH AVENATTI OR ANY OF THE
PEOPLE HE WORKED WITH.
IT SEEMS TO ME HE BROKE SOME
LOSS.
>> THIS DOXXING SO-CALLED
INCIDENT, I WASN'T FAMILIAR WITH
THE TERM BUT YOU DESCRIBED IT,
THIS PERSON HAS BEEN NOW CHARGED
WITH THIS CRIME WILL BE CHARGED
WITH, AS I UNDERSTAND, MULTIPLE
OFFENSES.
THIS IS NOTHING TO TOY AROUND
WITH.
IT'S SERIOUS BUSINESS.
FORTUNATELY THE CAPITOL POLICE
AND METRO POLICE ARE HANDLING
THIS SERIOUS, SERIOUSLY.
AS FAR AS MR. AVENATTI IS
CONCERNED, I WASN'T EAGER TO
PROVIDE HIM A PLATFORM FOR MORE
OF HIS PUBLICITY SEEKING.
OBVIOUSLY THE ALLEGATIONS MADE
BY MS. SWETNICK, NO ONE
CORROBORATED THOSE.
SHE HAS WALKED BACK FROM THOSE.
WITNESSES WHO ARE ASKED, LIKE
MARK JUDGE COME ABOUT THAT WERE
ASKED SAID IN NO WAY DID IT
HAPPEN.
WE HAVE NO CONFIRMATION OF ANY
OF THESE TERRIBLE ALLEGATIONS
AND THE JUDGE'S UNEQUIVOCAL
DENIAL IT EVER HAPPENED UNDER
PENALTY OF FELONY.
>> Greg: HOW CAN HE NOT BE
DISBARRED?
>> I THINK THE WAY MS. KATZ, THE
LAWYER MS. FEINSTEIN RECOMMENDED
FOR DR. FORD AND MR. AVENATTI
AND OTHERS HAVE NOT
DISTINGUISHED HIMSELF BY THEIR
CONDUCT AND THE APPROPRIATE FORM
FOR THEM TO BE REVIEWED IS
THROUGH THE BAR ASSOCIATION,
THROUGH THE ETHICS COMMITTEE.
THEY HAVE DISCIPLINARY AUTHORITY
AND THEY CAN DISCIPLINE OR
POTENTIALLY DISBARRED PEOPLE.
>> Dana: ONE LAST QUESTION
FROM JUAN WILLIAMS.
>> Juan: SENATOR CORNYN, YOU
ARE A DIGNIFIED GUY.
I LIKE YOU A LOT.
YOU ARE ON A BRAWL HERE ON
"THE FIVE."
LET'S START THE BRAWL.
>> Dana: WE ONLY HAVE A
MINUTE.
>> Juan: POLITICIZATION OF THE
SUPREME COURT, I WOULD HOPE IT
WOULD CONCERN YOU.
BUT YOU REFUSED TO LOOK AT
MERRICK GARLAND.
HE SAID HE WOULDN'T CONSIDER IT.
NOW YOU ARE IN A SITUATION WHERE
DEMOCRATS ARE SO UPSET OVER THIS
PROCESS THAT'S PRODUCED JUDGE
KAVANAUGH, I WORRY THAT THE
COURT ITSELF IS GOING TO, LIKE
SO MANY AMERICAN INSTITUTIONS,
ABSOLUTELY GO DOWN IN THE TRUST
FACTOR AMONG AMERICANS.
>> JUAN, SINCE THE BORK
HEARINGS, THOSE WARS HAVE
ESCALATED WITH THE NUCLEAR
OPTION BY HARRY REID TO PACK THE
D.C. CIRCUIT COURT.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS HAS GOTTEN
WORSE AND WORSE.
I HOPE WE HAVE REACHED THE END
OF THAT AND WE CAN RETURN TO US
MORE DIGNIFIED PROCESS, BOTH TO
THE NOMINEE AND THAT WOULD
REFLECT WELL ON THE SENATE.
WE HAVE A LOT OF HARDBALL
PLAYED.
I THINK WE ARE REAPING THE
WHIRLWIND.
>> Juan: I THINK BLOCKING, YOU
KNOW, MERRICK GARLAND JUST
STICKS IN SO MANY PEOPLE'S CROP.
A TWICE ELECTED PRESIDENT AND
YOU WON'T LET HIM BE CONSIDERED.
YOU MIGHT SAY KAVANAUGH WAS
UNFAIRLY TREATED BUT YOU
WOULDN'T EVEN GIVE MERRICK
GARLAND A CHANCE, A FAIR
HEARING.
>> THIS IS THE BIDEN PRECEDENT.
HE SAID YOU DON'T CONFIRM A
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE DURING A
PRESIDENTIAL YEAR.
IF HILLARY CLINTON HAD WON COME
I DON'T THINK WE WOULD BE
HEARING ANYTHING ABOUT MERRICK
GARLAND.
BECAUSE PEOPLE CHOSE
PRESIDENT TRUMP, HE CHOSE